you call it the backups Teddy names  he'll I don't throw the footballer  lineup under center I'm not  old-fashioned like you you are three  years older than me coach says we have  to play nice with them I want the both  of you on this everyone's gonna be so  confused someone has taken out starters  based on the seven QB sins greed soft oh  this is so comfy gratnik i'm so hungry  for knowledge I'll be back with the  jacket on the playoffs yes it was my  first kiss and then I just want the rush  to treat me the see now that's only six  there's one more quarterback are you nut  job we lost good man in Big Bear don't  you see no quarterback is greater than  the almighty shield it's a six game  injury you guys only need to win like  three games holding on the offense Vince  Lombardi once said winners never quit  and quitters never win I agree with the  second part if you want to see more  videos like this subscribe to the  channel